just use the white rook just grab all of  black's pawns on the left side  clear up that side of the board and then  refocus on getting to the black king  um he's got all the time in the world  here black's knight and queen are  completely passive  stuck defending the black king um  [ __ ] yeah he can just barely move and  i think if the bishops leave the board  now  it's only going to be two or three moves  before he gives up  okay he mama jarov doesn't go for the  simple approach playing bishop takes  bishop  he guards his bishop instead with a pawn  i said sadistic earlier that's even more  sadistic  he's just uh he has been a bit mean  actually maybe so many times he could  have put the boot in you know he could  have won the queen  he says no i'm gonna just go for  positional dominance  and okay well actually we do have a  result  and hikaru nakamura has resigned  and what a game by shakira mamajarov wow  it's a tithe in this  semi-final between hikaru nakamura and  shakira